hello and welcome to the Shakey's on
show in this video we'll look at the
links between depression and the
microbiome so in my previous video I
introduced the microbiome as being the
trillions of microorganisms that are in
our bodies and so let's start then with
a definition of depression so depression
is a medical condition and it's a mood
disorder that causes a persistent
feeling of sadness and depression is now
one of the leading causes of disability
worldwide and so the world health
organization currently predicts that
more than 264 million people suffer with
depression and Germany more women seems
to be affected than men and it's
important to understand depression and
correctly diagnosed it since it can lead
to suicide being the second leading
cause of death for 15 to 29 year-olds
and so the aim of this video is to
discuss some of the current evidence we
have out there for understanding the
links between the causes of depression
and the microbiome in particular
focusing on this nature paper here but
also taking some information from this
book brain maker by David Perlmutter I
canif I plant it and say he discusses
some evidence about the diets as well
with how that can into relate with
depression so does those things we'll
talk about in this video and I think
it's a really interesting area that not
much research has been done but there's
enough out there that it's something I
really wanted to talk about and I think
it's very interesting and there's a lot
yeah it still to be discovered so let's
just jump straight in so this connection
between depression and the guts
microbiome links to the big axes which
is the brain immune guard axes and I'm
so embarrassing I start brainer on but
it's too late now
and so before we look at some of the
findings from the nature paper I'll just
provide some quick facts that's its
current currently already known so
antidepressants are thought to work by
increasing the levels of serotonin which
is a neurotransmitter in the brain but
whilst it acts on the brain they it also
acts in the gut as well and actually the
highest concentrations of serotonin
and in the gods and say not only are the
highest concentrations found there but
the gut microgram isms not only
modulates the levels of host production
of serotonin but they can also produce
serotonin as well and so already there's
a connection between the presence of
certain micro biota and the levels of
serotonin and it's not just serotonin
the microbiome synthesizes short chain
fatty acids like B traits which are
precursors to other signaling molecules
neurotransmitters not only serotonin but
also gaba and hormones such as cortisol
the stress response hormone and so and
also immune system modulator z' but yeah
there's definitely connection between
the micro organisms and the brain and so
the questions are which bacteria are
responsible for the production of these
different molecules so for example it's
known that serotonin is highly regulated
by the microbiome and is produced by by
feed a bacterium infantis but besides
serotonin there really isn't that much
known about other bacterium and what
they produce so one of the aims of this
paper was to try and look at the
microbiome composition and see how that
correlates with depression and they did
this by looking at the population cohort
so they took the Flemish gut flora
project but datasets which had around a
thousand people in it and they looked at
the microbiome and looked at the
connection between the composition and
the quality of life scores that the
different patients recorded so quality
of life was recorded through a
questionnaire the round 36 health survey
and so it's included things such as
social functioning emotional well-being
vitality and then physical functioning
and body pain and some others as well
and then they did that for the quality
of life and then the data that they had
was from fecal DNA extraction where by
sequencing the 16s ribosomal RNA and
Abell them to detect the different
bacterial species so the idea then is
they can then look at the composition
and correlate that with the quality of
life score so if I bring up one of their
first figures here we can see that
they've categorize different enterotypes
and so enterotypes are just one way that
you can classify different groups of
bacterial species and so if you look at
the graph what we can see is that the
lower scores for quality of life show an
association with the bacterial DS in
theory type 2 and so you can see that
officially in both plots here and so
that's interesting and then not only did
they look at the intera type they also
then looked at specific bacterial
species that also correlate with lower
quality of life scores and so if I bring
up that figure we can look at that data
as well so here you can see different
species of bacteria and how they
correlate with a different quality of
life scores but also with some data from
previous literature as well so you kind
of the key data points that stand out as
you can see that the three top bacterial
species and I'll try and pronounce
figure really carefully that one capri
caucus and I list oh they seem to show
um having a higher composition of those
has a correlation with a higher quality
of life score whereas having a higher
composition of flower vani factor that
right I'm a correlated with a biased
quality of my score and there's also
actual reports in the literature that
have shown having an increased revenue
factor was reported in major depression
disorder patients so the Sator is
potentially interesting but so far it's
just correlations you know why is there
a high correlation but certain bacterial
species and depressions and others so to
answer this question the author's then
try to assess the neural active
potential of the different microbial
species and so they did this by looking
at all of the literature and looking at
the like the DNA of the different
species
as to what jeans they kind of possess
and they tried to make this huge
metabolic reconstruction framework well
as I said they took this message anemic
data and the use of the literature to
try and categorize and catalog the
different virtual species and what
different molecules that they're
synthesizing and they came for it's the
first catalog that's for maids I think
that is truly a master case and so they
group them into these got brain modules
gbm's and we found that three of these
gbm's Co fairies with the mental quality
of life scores say what were these three
different gbms so the first GBM
identified the synthesis of a deeper me
metabolite 3/4 I hydroxy phenyl acetic
acids as correlating positively with
mental quality of life from now on I'm
going to refer to it as Jay Park and the
second and third GBM are both related to
the synthesis of gaba which is the
neurotransmitter I mentioned earlier but
let's firstly look at the link of Deepak
and so what they found in the study is
that Deepak is actually known to be
synthesized by corporate caucus which
was one of the bacterial species they
pointed out earlier so already there
seems to be a connection between having
this bacterial species having more
Deepak and reducing the rates of
depression and the poverty showed the
association of cover and aspirated -
glutamate synthesis and degradation
so degradation is decreased and cover
synthesis is increased in patients with
depression from yesterday
and so you Gabor's the main inhibitory
neurotransmitter in the brain so you can
kind of look at this data set and go
yeah the kind of makes sense but as I
said before this is at the moment just
correlations not necessarily causations
all of these findings need further
individual follow-up and I mean that's
one of the limitations with these
studies you can find out lots of
interesting facts but they're just
correlations they
knife ascertain if this is the case and
also of the study they they kind of just
assess the composition and assess the
neural active potential they didn't
really look at the actual levels of the
new routes of compounds in the different
patients so that's also something to do
and also they did it in a population or
just one population right I mean it's
different ninety many other populations
they should probably look at and as I
mentioned in the previous video we know
that the microbiome is also influenced
by diet and by geographical location and
so taking that into account into the
study as well which could be definitely
confounding factors with their results
should also be considered and so I think
this study was really cool but they just
kind of need to figure out whether and
how these different microbe divided
molecules can actually interact with the
brain and the central nervous system as
it could have therapeutic application so
going back to diet um I read a chapter
from brain maker which was all about
this current studies out there that have
also looked at the link between
depression and the microbiome and so
I'll just give you a couple of the key
interesting facts I read in this book
and since the first one was that they
found that women with diabetes were more
likely to get diagnosed with depression
like there are 30% more likely to
develop depression than those who didn't
have diabetes and so the author kind of
speculates bit more in this by saying
that maybe it's not surprising that as
we see these global increases and the
rates of depression
there's also increases in obesity and
type 2 diabetes and given that kind of
information is behind a lot of these
different diseases there could be
something there as well so I think
that's very interesting and yeah I think
definitely he's on to something there
and another interesting fact he talks
about was breastfeeding and how in one
study they found that 72% of people who
didn't have depression were breastfed
whereas 46% of people who had depression
were breastfed so breastfeeding seems to
well you know we know it's when you
increase your diversity of the
microbiome and so maybe there's a
relationship there between
being breastfed and your microbiome and
suppression and the other thing he talks
about is the link to diet and I thought
to show you as a kid called food
Hospital where they said how you can try
and cure lots of different diseases by
modulating your diet I'm so it's
interesting then that there's been quite
a few different studies that have shown
that having a Mediterranean diet could
improve depression scores in a depressed
cohort and it's kind of linked onto this
whole field of nutritional psychiatry
and I mean I don't know too much about
this but I think that it's something
that's kind of getting to momentum a bit
more in the upcoming years um so yeah I
hope this has been a good introduction
to the link between microbiome and
depression and also this was about the
science but if you for any reason ever
feel like you might have depression you
just have to do that there's always
people that you can talk to you and so
I've put this website here um I know
it's available in the UK I just wanted
to mention it given the title of my
video but as always thanks for listening